hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to myth of Empires what
claims to be a MMO sandbox so imagine if
you started out as like a a naked
peasant in the middle of the woods with
nothing but a rock near underwear and
you had to bash a tree and to build a a
bodega and then you got to put a wall
around your Bodega and then you gotta
put a farm around your Bodega and then
you got to get other people to put their
bodegas by your Bodega and then you
build up a whole bunch of bodegas into a
super Bodega and then you build your
farms around and walls into Super walls
and super farms and then eventually you
have a castle and then you have all
those people that made their bodegas and
you get them to make more bodegas it's
like a pyramid scheme of bodegas but
then you have an Empire and thus I have
explained what human society is all
about
you're welcome also this is sponsored by
the developers of myth of Empires thank
you very much but my opinions are all my
own I've never played this before I have
no idea so if you enjoy what you see be
sure to click on the link in the
description below and check it out for
yourselves or you could wait until I get
my official opinion of it which will
come exactly as it appears in my mind I
withhold no opinions anyway
version doesn't match I don't know
virgin doesn't well how about hold on
for a second I wouldn't put this against
the game because the game is not out yet
and uh they gave this code to me like
two weeks ago and I was supposed to play
it before the game you know it's close
beta got shut down but it might have
already gotten shut down oh boy all
right so I'm gonna troubleshoot this and
then I'll be back definitely on the same
day when I'm able to play this for real
I'll see you in a bit okay bye I'm back
and as you can see nothing has changed
so I'm not even back I've been here the
whole time
nothing's wrong now
I am going to get this under way I
imagine I'm gonna start out in the
middle of nowhere with absolutely
nothing to my name and I'm gonna have to
talk my way to the top which is what I'm
very good at I say good words and stuff
eloquent
I'm naked height fat
muscles where's my muscles
the muscle slider doesn't seem to be
working
huh interesting
[Music]
and they're good okay well that was fun
while it lasted all right middle middle
middle middle because whatever
ah yeah sure face right
excellent great excellent
oh my God
oh wow is this handsome Squidward
[Laughter]
oh yeah you know what
this is great already I love a
comprehensive oh
I love a comprehensive uh character
customizer gels what gels it's all
Jawbone at that point there's no jowls
left all muscle all the time
save that template I'm gonna need that
oh
Mo yeah MO is Mo I'd say this is Mo
hair
eyes
what are you looking at
oh oh nice nose defined like a Greek god
yes
we have really found
the prime example of what a human should
look like
really excavate to kiss this man you
know he's gonna you gotta figure out how
your Anatomy will interface so you can
access these lips you think just anybody
could no it's like a key in a lock and a
door you gotta find the right hole
this is great
all right here we go yep get those back
get those up get those up get those and
put those to the side
are we trying to pick up radar here
yes we are
[Music]
I'd like to think his ears just twitch
naturally to the music that's happening
around him hair
yeah beard
[Music]
I love him
I love him
I love him oh my God what is this how
much wolf is in this man an incredible
amount oh tattoo
why why why is it so high up was it all
the way up in the face
yeah maybe maybe bring that down a bit
stretch that out a bit
[Music]
oh yeah that's my man Mo I mean I kind
of already picked his name as Mo so I'm
just gonna make him MO
oh no that's okay Moe is too generic
they call me Mr Moe Mr Moe all right I
literally spent way too long just on
that I don't know how to play this game
but Mr Moe is going to destroy whoa I
don't know what this means okay so from
what I think all of these are player
built places
let's go to
try that that looks good PVE or PVP well
I imagine if I do a PVP I'm gonna get
killed immediately so let's try that's
got good ping I like that so this is an
MMO so there are other people now
whether or not I'm gonna be able to talk
to them with my voice is a big question
but we shall see
oh alluvial plane you will reborn in
alluvial plane one
cool
novice mode is recommended for novice
players novice players can get better
experience at the beginning and adapt to
the game sooner there can Revive on the
spot give up I I guess I'll try it okay
operation mode Mo mode oh
myth of Empires right I am Mr Mo all
right click on the button below okay
Classic boat well I guess the more
complicated one would be better right
higher skill cap or whatever Ultra Mo
mode oh yeah
this world belongs to Mr Moe I'd open
inventory choose expertise along with a
flashing button okay
expertise
physique oh yeah we're gonna need
physique
okay wood cunning
all right
I can't I don't have any profibancy
collect
I got a rubble
I got a rubble
I got a branch
you got a rubble
got a grass
pricked that tree up I got a rubble
stick oh piggums I'm gonna freaking
watch some of this okay I have no idea
how to fight but I'm gonna [ __ ] this
boar up
yo you can't sleep on this did you fall
over and play dead because you knew Mr
Moe was coming oh both of you did yeah
you better be afraid of Mr Moe can I
sneak attack while you're sleeping whoo
oh
yeah yeah take that oh God I'm gonna die
oh no no Mr Moe doesn't like this oh no
not Mr Moe well I feel like when I first
started playing World of Warcraft and I
uh ran to the higher level areas but um
usually I can kill a boar Mr Moe's back
ah Mr Moe's corpse is uh
not doing so good all right thank you
that did not go well
this glowy thing over there big place oh
is that like another player oh
hello
you okay well you're napping so I guess
I'll leave you to it not that I could do
anything anyway
I gotta build something
I guess X to claim reward oh
is that another player
I am tired no that's a horse
I'm gonna go punch a horse horsey it's
got a skull like oh don't be afraid of
Mr Moe
no run away Mr Moe is friendly Mr Moe's
tired now you in this round there's got
to be like a crafting uh straw rope I
need to make straw ah it is it is Crafty
style I have locusts
I'm gonna eat that
I ate it
all right so I made that so now I can
make stone necks
craft
I'm gonna chop it down a tree how long
does that take so long 10 seconds what
is this do I have them do I have a monax
yet okay ax I know the basic premise of
most survival games so I'm assuming this
isn't too far off from that I got a chop
down tree hell yeah
sure oh
[Music]
hell yeah
this tree gonna fall oh there it goes
take one of them
this
did I get it I think I get as much as I
can get once I whack this thing enough
hardwood that's probably different bark
okay all right cool nice Mr Moe is
strong okay expertise I probably can do
an expertise now all right physique uh
physique level 12. what the hell level
16 wood cutting what do you mean level
five craft oh utensils that's a campfire
that's not a utensil I unlocked it of
course pull alarm throwing Rock I like
rocks
do I just unlock it do I have another
point I probably have points and I
probably yeah there we go recipe points
okay fill the belly grilled fish
skewered locusts okay let's that sounds
gross let me get some armor let me get
this filling of my belly and Voile
throwing Stone perfect nice okay
we are off to a great start
I'm level four now turns out you can
level up by running through bushes and
spamming e
incredible Elder I didn't did I have a
oh oh collect oh collect grab oh
but I can't
oh oh oh oh oh
ah down there oh okay let's get my
physique up Mr Moe's a little uh
A little sluggish you know what I mean
okay then we got the hammur let's make
it let's make pretty much all of this
okay and then I need to chop down more
trees which is fine because I need bark
X to claim reward I did it I did it I'm
level five now everyone
look upon my glorious body and weep okay
craft straw rope I'm doing that thing I
don't have enough grass why don't I have
enough grass is there a map
neutral Camp River Bandit and then
there's some kind of like City over
there
oh this place big okay all right I think
what eventually I'll probably have to do
is I'll probably try to go towards
whatever that is and then reach some
kind of communication once I get myself
outfitted with like the generics of you
know armor and such as like as the such
as that as the such as is the like as
the such as that then I'll be good to go
this is the part of the of games that I
just like always gravitate towards looks
like the the Gathering and like the
going to get things I don't know why it
just like hits the hunter-gatherer part
of my brain really really hard and I
just I don't know why I love it I could
go through these bushes like all day
X did it okay Stone and wood did that
stone ax did it Hammer put it in taskbar
bam did that X reward craft and place
campfire time for the survival part of
this before I do this what would happen
if I go to a PVP realm I just I'm kind
of curious as to what would happen
because how that this splash screen is
what I'm really looking for okay PVP uh
uh what if we do if I die right away we
we will reevaluate this decision I mean
I think Mr Moe's ready
it's level five you gotta watch out for
Mr Moe
tough isn't it level seven even
interesting
nothing looks different except maybe the
placement of those buildings around here
okay so it seems to be kind of the same
place well now I'm on a PVP server and I
don't know what difference that made
well time to build uh how do we do that
nope that ain't it learn blueprint
utensil in the recipe ah oh oh
building and Furniture wooden foundation
simple stronghold
defensive wooden support
okay that's good I seem to have a lot of
unlock points also let me get some armor
up oh interesting you build it in your
inventory and then you place it ah I
better get a spear up probably gonna
need more rope
okay
I don't see a campfire
campfire your campfire
Rubble straw rope okay well that's some
I don't have Rubble where do I get
Rubble I was getting so much Rubble in
the beginning and then I got absolutely
no ah here we go so let me equip my
newly found stuff
hell yeah
oh yeah
did that do it
oh okay all right let's see if those
boars want to tussle this time well [ __ ]
say oh
yeah
hey y'all
piercing oh my God ah two I didn't count
on two
I only wanted one
oh too bad for you I'm incredible Fox
you can't run no no no no this was a
this is what a throwing rock is for this
is what a throwing rock is for get ready
for throw
yes
yes all right what do I do with you how
do I get your meat give me your meat
give me your meat yes no no come on now
yeah get it get that meat
oh there it goes where's that other body
could I do that to a human
there you go okay oh more foxes maybe
next time Pals maybe next time I got
more Rubble to get
whoa is that a player character
hello
hey how you doing hey good to see ya
hey don't mind me just looking for rocks
you wouldn't hurt a guy looking for
rocks would ya
what is that supposed to be a caribou
is that one of them Caribou can you
carry a budai
well whatever can I get some goddamn
rocks please when did I when did I not
get any rocks I just I literally need
like one more rock rock
there we go
okay one more rock blammo
I like a nice Beachside view to my
Chateau Mr Moe's Chateau he likes to
live in a little bit of style you know
campfire
and blam love it personal ownership Mr
Moe I love it
roast Locus on the campfire
I would love to I would love to roast
locusts on the
I would I would I would love to roast
some locusts on the campfire Warrior
food
hell yeah
Go baby go oh wait skewered I'm supposed
to actually wait no stop don't fuse that
I don't know what you're refusing oh
wait no oh I get it
oh I see the locusts are in the pot ow
am I on fire was I standing in my own
fire with someone trying to kill me I'll
kill you back Mr Mo don't take lightly
to that can I uh get these I'm gonna
appease my Hunger
yum
yum oh I was starving that's what did it
it's not so much that someone was trying
to kill me as I was starving okay not a
lot of food but whatever got something
of course pole arm Throne Rock already
done wooden spear crafty ah more rocks
all right fine
X okay put in protective gear okay got
that hunt rabbits for animals to get the
meat I did oh
I'm gonna again hey pal
oh
come on come on come on come at me come
at me
yeah
yeah oh yeah
you want some of this
take that oh excellent
can I get some meat off of it did I get
any meat I did get meat I got raw meat
baby I got raw meat side mark on the map
M right click to add a marker
dead fox I'm Mark I loved it its name
was all right
R.I.P foxy
done claim reward grill meat on campfire
you got it big boy please tell me
there's fishing in this game because
that'll make it the best game I've ever
played that automatically makes it the
best game I've ever played whenever I
have fishing in the game oh I had meat
from the other thing that I did have me
I was just dumb okay I got me nine eat
meat
crafter Shield did it craft a bow and
arrow okay I need 20 stone arrows I
don't have 20 stone you and your goddamn
rocks what if I hit if I hit Rock
oh
there we go oh my God I'm incredibly
strong can I bash up this stuff nah
didn't think so
I think a hammer would work better for
this I don't know why
equip that hammer no
why am I not hitting this thing
oh am I disconnecting
oh oh
I think the server might be crashing
up there we go ah well I it's uh
whenever these MMOs get launched and
this one launched like yesterday uh
there's a lot of instability so I think
that's to be expected unless my internet
went out
oh my internet went out oh I see well
I'll be back I'll be back once again
when I figure my internet out on the
next time on Markiplier can totally play
a game I'm a professional YouTuber whose
entire life depends on my access to the
internet
I'm back Mr Moe is here and he's ready
and I'm gonna get rid of Shield because
I looked at the pictures and I think
that it maybe not necessary but whatever
Mr Moe is here what was my objective uh
arrows rocks rocks and arrows
High Horse by horse
wonder when I'll be able to get a horse
I'll drag the arrow onto the bow oh I
see ah that makes more sense I get it
now X
hunt any animal and skin it what I
I did that already I'm not
I'm not gonna no I couldn't I shouldn't
less
[Laughter]
oh
skin it is that oh well uh turns out I'm
terrible
fox skin it is
it's coming right for me yeah oh oh oh
really oh wow oh yeah that's what you'll
get us what you get
hey
all right got that bed roll all right
bedroll bedroll bedroll bedroll grass
God damn it ah there's so many things
necessary join a guild how do I join a
guild I don't know how to join a guild
how do I join a guild
Federal
okay so the interesting thing is how do
I join a guild I don't even know how to
talk to people I I'm I'm afraid that's a
boar payback time [ __ ] payback time
[ __ ] I'm trying to get my spirit out
payback time [ __ ]
you're tougher than oh my God okay okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold on hold on hold your phone here
yeah
wow
how about this one of these that's what
I thought that's what I thought that's
what I thought I'm hungry I'm hungry for
some boar I think this would probably be
easier with like a knife or something
oh I guess that's it
well I did it
I am the best where'd my fire go
I thought it was over here somewhere
oh God what is all that ensure safety
build a house
okay I need to build a wooden foundation
okay wooden foundation I need to build a
wooden support structure
what does that mean like a wall
wall support structure meaning wall I
probably need four walls and a territory
Banner
okay where's my fire I had a fire here
somewhere just worn I was like I know I
was like 96 away from that foxy and I
might have to make a new one seems like
it might have despawned which is fine
whatever I can make another one
or I can't can I not make it until I
find my fire is that what the deal is I
don't know where my fire went and I
don't think I can build a new one until
I get my fire oh I need four wooden
foundation okay three of those wait what
am I missing why can't I build any more
oh branch oh I see okay so the quest
continues to get more stuff uh
eventually I will get it why couldn't I
make a campfire because I didn't have
the branches that's right they were all
committed okay more stuff on the way
oh am I so nice oh
my ex
no who can I level up have I been able
to level up for a while now probably ooh
weave ooh fishing that's a harpoon
that's not what I thought it would be
pretty cool I guess Soldier clothes ooh
a ladder wooden City defense ooh can I
defend a city oh now that's what I want
to do I want to be all City defense
ooh wooden protective gear
which is what I have but it's rough but
that's okay how far does this tree go
of all right okay
you want to go tree you want to go you
want to tussle with the muscle you want
to tussle you don't want to tussle you
can't tussle not with this muscle not
with this muscle not with my muscle
we'll punch a tree down any day come on
tussle with my muscle you couldn't
tussle what am I crafting do I have an
ax yet where's where's my ax okay I'm
crafting it just a little longer on the
muscle would you want to deal some oh
you want some of this muscle oh I don't
think you could handle this muscle the
tussling you couldn't deal with oh
that's right from behind from every
witch away from left from right from
nine o'clock from ten o'clock you've
never seen the muscle Mr Mo that's a lot
of foxes that's I'll take you all on
I'll take you all on the muscles don't
tussle the muscle don't tussle you can't
tussle my muzzle
right in your stupid Fox jaw you ain't
never ever coming back to this
neighborhood again that's more foxes oh
okay all right well okay so the muscle
also has a fair
oh oh God oh God please no not like this
not like this
oh hey you'll never get it you'll never
get it you'll never get it you'll never
get me you'll never get me I
I Never Surrender
yeah
did I do it
did it
I did it all of you couldn't tussle with
my muscle I am the Slayer of foxes Mr
Moe Knows No Mercy can I do anything to
heal myself or is that just gonna happen
over time
all right thank you for the answer I
should make a door
I should make a roof it's finally time
to build my home okay we're gonna lay
out some found a woo
oh Auto absorption what does that mean
oh God oh God oh God
yeah that's pretty cool actually I don't
mind that hot shot
look at that
everyone watch how hero you better watch
yeah
I don't know what you were thinking but
uh you didn't know what was gonna happen
when Mr Moe was gonna turn up and Mr Moe
did turn up yes he did yes he did
I know how to whistle now my reward
please
build a door frame and a window frame
okay craft the wooden wall okay I need
two more wooden walls I thought I built
a door I did build a door
toggle ah
oh
uh-huh oh oh oh oh
oh I'm building it I'm building it guys
it's actually coming together I can't
believe it
oh big door
ah bam pretty nice guys pretty nice done
hunting knife how in the hell was I
supposed oh
hunting knife uh put Stone hunting knife
in sidebar click course hide get linen
how do I make linen make Linen on the
spinning wheel okay how do I make a
spinning wheel this is a lot of stuff
all of a sudden how do I join a guild I
don't really know him is this gonna burn
my house down probably all right let's
plop her in okay Spinning Wheel got it
that's gonna take a while I better go
get more stuff huh
close with that yeah no one will ever
know
oh
no no no no no no
it's fine
it's fine I can get Dino it's all about
overcoming obstacles
I can't put that there
there we go
bada buoy easy
we make do with the hen that we're dealt
my friends the hand that were dealt can
I move this I shouldn't have put it
right in the middle you know right in
the middle wasn't exactly where I wanted
it to be okay right in the doorway yeah
that's that's where I'd want it to be
perfect
oh
what do I do grass
grass Warrior food grass linen flax bark
flax bark
I'm making linen is that a horse
the horse will never see it coming well
I wonder if I can tame a horse I saw in
the picture there was people horsey
come to me be my friend all right fine
not helping me be the man that I need to
be I need to be a more man I want to
conquer Empire
tame horse
yes yes yes tame horse yes team horse
yes team horse yes I want a horse can I
have horse I would like horse please I'm
gonna make a rain a saddle I'm gonna
make it all all right I'm gonna get this
goddamn horse I don't even know how to
get a horse but I'm gonna get a horse
because the horse is key to my freedom I
need to get into town I'm too big for
this Forest I'm more than this Forest
could ever handle control arm your
Renown is enough to what oh what the
hell
I'm a commoner
whoa that's pretty good I guess but hey
that's pretty good so there is like a
social projection
progression and as soon as I get to the
point where I can meet other people and
then mess them up with my skill they're
gonna know the pain that is Mr Moe all
right I'm assuming that it's something
about I gotta like rain this thing in
needed some fodder why is that why can
that only go in five that doesn't make
any sense why would that only be able to
go to Five whatever you know what I'm
not gonna question it it's fine all
right
it's night
night perfect time to hunt a horse I'm
gonna try to track me down a big
beautiful horse
I think I have it equipped nope that's
not how you would do it
okay I have I've got something out maybe
I hold out the food I have the food ah
take my take my food
can I God I just wasted that didn't it
go oh it's fine it's gonna make more
I'm gonna make a lot more that's all I
need of course
too big beautiful horses all right get
ready horses you're about to know the
joy that is fodder
eat my fodder
[Music]
oh come on oh
no no not too close I'm not too close oh
you don't see me
but that one's eating the fodder far
you want the fodder no no no no I'm not
here oh God
that's okay that's okay that's okay it's
a process here fodder for you
father yeah pretty good fod you like the
fod awesome Good Friday maybe I sneak up
on you while you're munching the fod oh
you don't say nothing
oh you don't see nothing
subduing huh oh yeah I'm subduing it
I'm mounting you
haha you've been mounted
ah no you're mine you're mine you're
mine you're mine we're friends we're
friends we're friends this is how we
friend no no no no no no no no no no no
no no the rage is in increasing a lot
whoa Nelly whoa speed up yeah yeah
good yeah good very good the rage is
incredible excellent perfect excellent
excellent oh yeah excellent this is
excellent the rage calm down don't let
the rage consume you okay all right the
rage seems to be reaching a peak
um hold on to yourself your soul you
remember all we've been through remember
when I gave you the dry fodder
pretty good right that's pretty good
yeah that's right just stay right here
man you are pissed
horse is about to go berserk interesting
uh about that oh oh oh I'm clicking I'm
clicking the left mountains button I'm
clicking it I'm clicking it I'm clicking
right
right Mouse butt left Mouse but I got it
I controlled your rage
dude it
you
and I are friends now oh that was level
22. oh that would have been a good one
but it's okay ah
Mr Joe together
we are Mr Moe and Mr Joe
I love you I love you you're my horse
and I love you take one of these take
one of these take some of this I don't
know if that did that work I don't know
it sure ah something in my eye
wow I've done it my destination
my destiny lies here it's time to begin
my quest
to my destiny
[Music]
well would you look at that is that
actual civilization oh never mind it's
broken uh to crap it's uh completely um
it's terrible did like a battle happen
here this place don't look so good huh
oh no it's fine
hello Hi how are you oh God it's Bandits
oh it was Bandits the whole time oh I'm
about to say you won't keep me from my
destiny
you are my vehicle uh his name is Mr Joe
and uh you would do well I didn't
realize this was just a whole band of
thing uh never mind I apologize thank
you and I'm sorry
been a long and hard journey to get to
this point I
I had the epic battle with the foxes I
slew many trees I gripped many young
plants out from its roots before it had
a chance to sprout and I did it with
Glee and I would do it again for nothing
can stand between me
my destiny I am but a lone soul in a sea
of other people chasing their own dreams
but Mr Moe will see them all Fallen to
the Wayside because I alone have come to
this world to claim supremacy of the
throne though I may be a lowly commoner
I know that over the crest of this
mountaintopped
world that's waiting with open arms to
receive me nothing can stand in my way
ah wolves wolves wolves are standing in
my way
wolves
wild run Mr Joe
Joe can you run any faster than you are
currently running there are wolves there
is a wolf on our tail there's one wolf
God Mr Joe please do not slow down at
any point in the near future Mr Joey
would be very bad for us also we seem to
be going a little bit away from our
destiny I thought the mountain back oh
God Mr Joe please Mr Joe I'm okay
Destiny there it is my destiny my dreams
await me in this place I shall claim
what is mine
I shall know Glory
uh uh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry this
is my destiny I'm oh uh
uh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh God run oh my God Mr
Joe oh my God
I said nothing is gonna stand in the way
of me and my destiny not you not your
catapults and not your stupid rocks
I'm going in there and there's not a
goddamn
I don't think I want to arrive on the
spot I'm going for it again my Destinies
lies in here destiny
mrimo coming in for Destiny
[Music]
from
my goal I know it's here I know it must
be
it's there
oh oh my ass oh why ax up my ass oh
Destiny calls to me I am the one who can
stand above all else I will know no
mercy for thee I will call upon the gods
of myself oh my ass
once again in my ass ow
I see it now it was it was Destiny not
Destiny it was I see it plainly Destiny
I think I was supposed to gather friends
to go
conquer that thing I think I was
supposed to get people to team up with
me the people talking in chat there I
was probably supposed to talk to them if
you would like to play this game with me
check the link in the description below
because clearly I need friends to be
able to take that over uh this game is
fun and apparently there's a big world
where you uh make it and uh your destiny
is whatever you decide you're able to
convince people to help you take and
that's what it's all about thank you
everybody so much for watching uh let me
know if you play this game and if you
can find me as Mr Mo in here and as
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]